cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north vpn
écoutez si je vous disais que vous
pouviez devenir comme doctor strange me
croyez vous et bien c'est le cas car
grâce à north bay pn tel le maître des
arts mystiques je peux vous proposer de
vous déplacer à travers les réalités
d'internet en toute sécurité en évitant
les menaces criminelles et la
surveillance comme pourrait incarner un
certain shuma-gorath et en plus de ça
vous permettre d'accéder à du contenu
que vous n'avez pas dans votre univers
avec norme bpmn en un seul clic vous
pouvez changer votre localisation depuis
chez vous ou n'importe quel endroit et
accéder au contenu que vous souhaitez
grâce à ça et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
principale de pourquoi j'utilise n'en
fait pn à titre personnel vous pourrez
accéder à du contenu inédit qui n'est
pas disponible en france par exemple si
vous changez votre localisation pour le
canada vous aurez accès sur dix n'est
plus à des films marvel récents comme
black widow chan chee ou même carrément
eternalz qui est disponible en vod
depuis seulement deux semaines
d'ailleurs on n'oublie pas de rappeler
que norme bpn possède une très bonne
vitesse d'exécution grâce à ses cinq
mille 200 serveurs répartis dans 60 pays
mais également que c'est accessible sur
six appareils différents si vous êtes
intéressé n'hésitez pas à accéder au
lien disponible en descriptions pour les
soldes d'hiver note vpn vous propose une
offre de deux ans avec une réduction de
70 % et un mois offerts satisfait ou
remboursé sur 30 jours merci à north bay
pn que la vidéo commence
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau trois théories dédié à spider
man noir où je trouve que nous n'avons
pas encore assez creuse et certaines
questions et d'ailleurs il commence à y
avoir pas mal de rumeurs et
d'explications depuis la sortie du film
et j'estime qu'il est grand temps que
l'on s'intéresse à tout ça en espérant
que la vidéo vous plaisent je vais vous
présenter ma vision personnelle
évidemment néanmoins il est possible que
plusieurs informations évolué vu comment
les choses avancent concernant spider
man mais bref voilà en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
plein de belles choses arrive que le
trois théories commence
[Musique]
bel
je souhaitais tout d'abord revenir sur
le cas de venom nous avions mentionné
son cas dans la vidéo d'après film mais
nous n'avions pas creusé plus que ça la
question une belle explication a fait
surface concernant ce dernier je
souhaitais vous en parler plus tôt mais
au final je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de le
faire je vous propose donc que l'on
revienne dessus maintenant et qu'on
essaye d'aller plus loin par rapport à
ce qui a été dévoilé en premier lieu il
faut recontextualiser la situation dans
spider man aux ehome dr strange a
expliqué à peter que ce dernier à
inverser le sortilège qui devait
normalement faire oublier que peter
était spider man ce qui veut dire que le
sort a finalement fait venir dans le mc
eu des entités qui savent que peter
parker spider man et c'est là que
c'était interpellant car venom dans ses
films et donc sa réalité ne nous a
jamais montré le moindre signe
d'existence ou de connaissance d'un
peter parker ou d'une araignée et bien
en fait c'est dû à la mémoire génétique
des symbiote pour faire simple les
symbiote sont une race extraterrestre
créé par le dieu ne l' une entité née
dans le vide primordial bien avant la
naissance de l'univers ces derniers
possèdent un esprit de ruches ce qui
sous-entend que les symbiote collaborent
entre eux comme un essaim sa porte du
savoir et des connaissances et du coup
ce fonctionnement existent notamment
grâce à cette capacité qui est définie
comme une mémoire génétique une mémoire
génétique qui permet à chaque sens biot
d'assimiler les émotions les traits de
caractère et les compétences de leurs
hôtes puis de les garder en réserve ce
qui va permettre à d'autres symbiote de
s'approprier tous ces éléments c'est
pourquoi carnage qui est un descendant
de venom possède les mêmes aptitudes que
son aïeul par exemple sauf que moi ce
qui m'avait perturbé c'était de savoir
si la mémoire génétique fonctionner à
l'échelle de l'univers ou à l'échelle du
multivers car ce n'est pas du tout la
même chose et les comics ne semblait pas
trop répondre à la question mais sony en
fait tout prévu puisque dans la scène
post générique de venom de venom et et
10 ont une conversation avant de subir
le changement de réalité une
conversation ou venom affirma est dit
dans la vo que la ruche a appris en
parcourant 80 milliards d'années lumière
à travers les univers puisqu'il est fait
mention du mot university choses que
l'on ne retrouvait pas dans la vf donc
vous l'aurez compris cela signifie que
la mémoire génétique s'étend à l'échelle
du multivers et par conséquent que venom
à assimiler certaines informations
vécues par d'autres symbiote dans le
multivers effectivement si venom se
sentent attirés par peter parker quand
il apparaît dans la télé c'est parce que
ce dernier a assimilé au moins les
émotions du venom associés aux édiles
broc incarné par topher grace dans la
trilogie spider man de sam raimi et pour
rappel ce venom scellier à spider man
puis fut rejetée par ce dernier avant
d'être tué par le peter de toby dans un
combat les opposants donc des éléments
forts qui ont dû marquer le venom
incarné par le eddie brock de tom hardy
maintenant si nous revenons à la scène
post générique de nos héros mme pour moi
venom a délibérément laissé un morceau
de lui même avant de partir car il ne
voulait pas quitter la réalité du m6
puisque il se sentait clairement attiré
par peter ce qui voudrait dire que venom
à un objectif et un plan nous allons
être très clair c'est évident pour moi
que venom souhaite récupérer les
pouvoirs de l'homme araignée c'est un
passage obligatoire pour le
développement du protagoniste dans son
histoire et dans les comics donc nous
allons forcément le retrouver à l'avenir
mais comment cela va fonctionner déjà il
ya un truc il faut mettre en lumière
c'est que venom ne peut pas avoir deux
autres c'est quelque chose qu'il a déjà
essayé dans les comics par le biais de
flash thompson et eddie brock et il ne
peut pas posséder les deux ce qui veut
dire que venom ne pourra pas avoir
recours aux petites heures dans le nc et
en même temps et 10 dans sa réalité et
par conséquent cela sous-entend
également autre chose c'est que ce petit
morceau de symbiote que venom a laissé
derrière lui volontairement deviendra
une entité à part entière forcément la
première chose à laquelle on pense c'est
que cela va être la naissance d'un
nouvel enfant entre guillemets de venom
un descendant comme carnage qui a été
influencé par cletus caisse est dit ici
en l'occurrence ce serait peter sauf
qu'il y a un problème pour moi avec
cette idée c'est que si on nous propose
un film spider man avec un symbiote
dédié dans le scénario et qu'au final ce
n'est pas venom et bien je pense que ça
va pas mal râler voir décevoir et parmi
tous les descendants de venom c'est un
avis personnel mais je ne pense pas
qu'il soit assez iconique il n'ya que
carnage je trouve qui sort du lot et il
a déjà été utilisé
donc j'ai peut-être une idée variante à
vous proposer pour moi ce petit morceau
de symbiote deviendrait un clone de
venom et je ne vous dis pas ça par
hasard déjà pour le symbole cela veut
dire que nous aurions à peter parker qui
se lit avec un venom donc les fans
seraient contents mais en plus pour la
cohérence de l'univers cela marche
puisque cela deviendrait une entité
propre et puis surtout c'est un cas qui
existe dans les comics ce petit morceau
de symbiote pourrait devenir magna magna
est un clone de venom créé à partir d'un
morceau de langue du venom original et
franchement cela pourrait donner quelque
chose de vraiment sympa mais bon cela
reste une idée comme ça néanmoins il y
un autre élément qui m'interpelle c'est
qu un symbiote a besoin d'un autre pour
prospérer et c'est quelque chose qui est
toujours retranscrit dans les films de
spider man c'est une règle qui a
toujours existé et d'ailleurs si on
relativise venom à la base était
accompagné d'eddy pour partir à la
recherche de peter venom à influencer et
10 pour aller retrouver l'homme araignée
sauf qu'ils ont disparu et maintenant
nous avons que ce petit morceau de
symbiote tout seul il va avoir besoin de
quelqu'un d'un hôte qui est à la
recherche de spider man lessard biot est
en très sensible aux émotions si ce
petit morceau de sel chez quelqu'un une
envie profonde de retrouver spider man
de fortes chances qu'il ait envie de se
lier à l'huile pour retrouver la reine y
est bien pour moi il existe une personne
un antagoniste qui a été teasé il ya
très longtemps et qui pourraient refaire
surface aujourd'hui c'est le scorpion
mcguigan possède une grande rancoeur
concernant spider man il est en prison à
cause de lui et la scène post générique
de homecoming nous l'a prouvé il veut
retrouver l'homme araignée et ce même
avec le sort de strange ils recherchent
spider man et non peter parker puisqu'il
ne connaît pas son identité de plus
c'est une fusion que l'on retrouve dans
les comics magan et venom ont déjà
collaboré puisque venom avait ressenti
la haine du scorpion envers spider man
et c'est ce qui l'avait poussé à le
choisir comme hôte enfin je vous en
avais déjà parlé mais sony souhaite
innover nous proposer toujours des
ennemis différents à chaque oeuvre c'est
pour ça que dans le m6 où nous avons
fait face à mystérieux ou encore le
vautour sans oublier tous les films qui
vont être développées comme morbius
kraven le chasseur et cetera et cetera
des antagonistes de spider man qui ne
sont encore jamais apparu à l'écran
magan en fait partie sachant qu'en plus
il a été teasé il y a longtemps sans
jamais revenir et qu'en plus il a déjà
collaboré avec venom et bien tout ça
pourrait prendre forme permettant d'
enfin réunir le symbiote et l'araignée
[Musique]
maintenant que les deux légendes ont
fait leur retour dans spider man aux
ehome il est légitime de se demander
s'il ya moyen de refaire une hype aussi
puissante avec d'autres personnages de
l'univers spider man et bien
personnellement je suis convaincue que
oui vous le savez tous ce n'est pas la
fin de spider man dans le m6 ou disney
et sony ont clairement fait savoir
qu'ils aiment collaborer ensemble les
résultats sont d'ailleurs plus que bon
et c'est pourquoi une nouvelle trilogie
a été annoncé et c'est là que c'est
intéressant car pour moi il ya encore
moyen d'élever la barre et de proposer
des dingueries avec l'univers de spider
man déjà du point de vue de sony nous
savons qu'ils ont clairement un plan
pour s'implémenter dans le m6 où c'est
vraiment leur objectif et pour cause
leurs films en association avec marvel
n'ont jamais été aussi populaire qu'en
étant lié à l'univers de disney et si
nous retraçons les oeuvres et les
prochaines productions de sony tout
devient canon omc ou par exemple venom
qui va jouer un grand rôle dans le futur
du spider man de tom holland ils vont
sortir des films sur des personnages de
l'univers de l'homme araignée qui seront
également lié à lui à un moment ou à un
autre je parle bien évidemment de
morbius ou encore craven par exemple et
rien qu'avec nos héros mme ils ont fait
quelque chose d'incroyable puisqu'ils
ont relié les films de tobey maguire et
andrew garfield avec le mc do donc si
l'on suit cette logique et bien il
existe une autre oeuvre qui devrait
possiblement tôt ou tard se lier avec le
marvel cinématiques universe et il
s'agit des films de spider man new
generation et across the spider verse
quand sony et disney ont commencé à se
contacter pour proposer une nouvelle
version de spider man qui s'intégrerait
omc ou une certaine hype a commencé à
apparaître le hashtag donald fort spider
man beaucoup de femmes se sont réunies
sur les réseaux sociaux pour propulser
l'idée que donald glover pourrait jouer
une version de miles morales un spider
man très iconique il s'est finalement
avéré que tom holland serait le nouveau
spider man néanmoins les fans ont été
quand même entendu puisque donald glover
jouera finalement un caméo en devenant
le personnage aaron d'avis dans
homecoming qui est en réalité l'oncle de
miles morales et accessoirement un
vilain d'ailleurs dans nos héros mme
électro en a rajouté une couche en
affirmant qu'il pensait que le spider
man andrew garfield était un spider man
noir et qu'il espère qu'il en existe un
dans le multivers donc voilà il ya
clairement une hype autour de miles
morales et s'est taillé pop sony en a
conscience et justement avec spider man
in to the spider verse ils ont pu
développer une origin story pour le
spider man 2 miles morales et là les
étoiles sont clairement alignés pour moi
puisque avec la logique de sony de
relier leurs productions du spyder verse
aux marvel cinématiques universe le fait
que miles morales possède déjà sa propre
histoire qui en plus va continuer avec
un second opus sans oublier que la saga
into the spider verse et principalement
liés à la thématique du multivers et
bien il y a clairement moyens de relier
tout ça le meilleur moyen pour moi
serait l'intégration d'un filin
permettant de relier les spider man
c'est quelque chose dont on a déjà parlé
dans de précédentes vidéos mais sony
cherche toujours à produire de l'inédit
concernant l'univers de spider man donc
voilà pour moi un film permettant de
relier miles morales spider guen
d'autres spider man possiblement et le
spider man de tom holland pourrait
s'effectuer avec l'arrivée d'un vilain
encore jamais vu à l'écran c'est mort
lounes mort lund je vous en avais déjà
parlé mais en gros c'est l'unique
méchants de l'univers de spider man qui
vient d'une autre réalité est qu'ils
peuvent voyager à travers multivers pour
résumer morlot ne fait partie d'un
groupe qu'on appelle les héritiers il
est celui qui va donner naissance au
spyder verse dans les comics puisque il
chasse les spider man dans tous les
univers et pour être plus précis il
chasse les spider man dit au public
c'est à dire celles et ceux qui ont été
mordu par une araignée pour acquérir
leur pouvoir ce dernier est un bon moyen
de relancer une hype spyder verse sans
avoir à utiliser docteur strange qui
d'ailleurs devrait normalement ne plus
se rappeler de peter parker la chasse de
meaulnes est ce qui a permis aux hommes
et aux femmes a régné de se rencontrer
et de s'unir face à un ennemi commun la
saga into the spider verse baignant
complètement dans la thématique du
multivers et de la rencontre des spider
man à travers les réalités la saga
pourrait mettre en place l'arrivée de
mort lund qui est complètement lié aux
mêmes thématiques pour une future
production peut être que ce dernier sera
utilisé seulement dans la saga dean to
the spider verse mais si ce n'est pas le
cas cela permettrait d'amener enfin
miles morales à l'écran dans un film en
live action surtout que la transition
entre dessins animés et films ne serait
pas vraiment dérangeante puisque déjà
par le biais de what if nous avons déjà
connu ce genre de changement d'ailleurs
il est fortement attendu de voir des
personnages de bois tiff arriver sur
grand écran comme captain carter qui
représente captain britain où je peux le
site est comme ça mais le suprême dr
strange qui est possiblement celui que
nous avons vu dans le trailer de dr
strange 2 mais également nous allons
avoir une série animée dédié à l'origine
story du peter parker de tom holland sur
dix n'est plus et là nous pouvons faire
une sorte de parallèle puisque comme
miles morales nous aurions une origin
story en animation avant d'avoir
possiblement une grande histoire dans un
film dédié en live action tout ça pour
dire que je suis convaincu et que c'est
largement faisable que nous aurons un
miles morales dans un film du mc ou un
jour ou l'autre tout comme une spyder
guen a vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez
bon docteur strange the multiverse of
madness est un film qui s'annonce très
particulier vous n'avez certainement pas
pu échapper à toutes les rumeurs
énormément de personnages sont attendus
dans le film et pour cause nous allons
pour la première fois nous rendre au
coeur du multivers donc marvel peut se
permettre des dingueries je vous
proposerai très certainement une vidéo
un peu plus générale sur dr strange de
et ses nombreux caméo mais il semblerait
que marvel souhaite nous proposer une
équipe unique d'avengers issus du
multivers le temps d'un film et du coup
il ya de très nombreuses rumeurs comme
quoi tobey maguire ferait son retour là
bas si on suit la logique de la team
d'avengers variant il incarnerait donc
le spider man de la team est en soi si
on sort du scénario et de l'univers toby
est toujours un grand ami de sam raimi
qui a été choisi pour réaliser le film
de doctor strange 2 sachant que c'est
lui qui a fait les premiers spider man
avec toby bon ce n'est pas idiot de se
dire que sam raimi lui a proposé une
place dans son film sachant que c'est
désormais permis et cohérent vu que nous
sommes dans le multivers mais au final
si cela devait arriver quel impact
aurait le retour de tobey maguire en
spider man dans l'univers du mc hugh je
vous avoue que si je souhaite vous en
parler c'est que je pense que quelque
chose peut découler du retour de ce
fameux spider man déjà tout simplement
car le speedy de toby a eu une
importance dans spider man no way home
donc si il revient dans doctor strange 2
cela signifie que le temps aura passé vu
que le second film du docteur se déroule
quelques temps après nos héros mme donc
nous pourrions être témoin d'une courte
évolution du personnage savoir comment
s'est passée son retour si son univers a
été impacté à cause des événements du
troisième film de l'homme araignée et
cetera etc mais pour moi il existe un
autre point intéressant et il faut que
nous retournions sur la base du sort
lancé par dr strange
comme précisé dans le film le sort a été
sabotée par le peter de tom holland et
au lieu de faire oublier son identité au
reste du monde cela a mené toutes les
entités connaissant l'identité de spider
man à travers les univers vers celui du
mc hugh la solution est au final de
lancer un second sort pour corriger le
1er mai qui cette fois ferait oublier à
tout le monde mais absolument tout le
monde l'identité de l'homme araignée
incarné par tom holland à travers le
multivers fui ce qu'il fallait refermer
les brèches amenant des entités
provenant d'autres univers connaissons
l'identité de peter et bien cela nous
explique dans toutes les réalités du
multivers le peter de tom holland a été
oublié plus personne ne sait qui c'est
donc ce soit ned michel rapide docteur
strange et du coup même les autres peter
où les vilains du film tout le monde l'a
oublié néanmoins pour moi la possible
rencontre entre stephen strange et le
peter de toby dans doctor strange 2
pourrait être un moyen pour le docteur
de se rappeler de l'identité de spider
man dans le mc hugh pourquoi tout
d'abord certains pourrait me dire que dr
strange je connais le spider man de
tobey maguire par le biais de nos rôles
et c'est le cas sauf qu'il ne va plus
rappelé de son nom et cela a son
importance ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que dans nos héros mme c'est le
peter incarné par tom holland qui va
présenter les autres spy dit au docteur
et il lui affirme bien que ce sont des
spider man et des peter parker comme lui
donc si tout le monde doit oublier
l'identité de peter parker cela veut
dire que cette présentation est passé à
la trappe car c'est le peter de tom
holland qui a présenté les autres speedy
à visage découvert et qu'en plus il
s'est basé sur lui même pour les
présenter est-ce que c'est clair pour
vous et c'est là que c'est pertinent car
du coup docteur strange ne se
souviendrait pas du véritable nom du
spider man de tobey maguire donc si il
la prend au cours du film cela pourrait
donner une piste pour doctor strange
pour retrouver l'identité du spider man
mc hugh car oui ce n'est pas parce qu'il
a oublié peter qu'il a oublié spider man
tout le monde se souvient de spider man
mais pas de son identité sachant que
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
va plonger dans le concept de variants
du genre possiblement à tony stark d'un
autre univers aride richard's d'une
autre réalité ou tout simplement
d'autres steven strange est bien le
docteur pourrait carrément faire le lien
entre les deux arts et demi d'ailleurs
on ne s'est pas encore véritablement
tout du sortilège mais il se pourrait
que le nom peter parker agissent comme
un déclic permettant de se rappeler de
tous il semble que le sortilège soit
l'élément perturbateur du film de doctor
strange 2 sauf que si on relativise
cela veut dire qu'il ne se souvient plus
véritablement de pourquoi il a lancé ce
sort puisque c'est lié à peter dont il a
oublié l'existence donc si par le biais
de toby steven à un déclic concernant le
nom peter parker cela pourrait l'aider
dans sa quête à retrouver les souvenirs
qui lui manquait dans tous les cas
l'oubli de l'identité de peter sert
avant tout à faire vs l'histoire du
personnage lui permettant d'avoir de
nouvelles aventures différentes de ces
premières mais à terme il est clair que
certains se rappelleront de qui il est
vraiment qui de mieux que celui qui a
été à l'origine du sortilège pour se
rappeler le premier surtout que étant
donné que steven est destiné à devenir
le sorcier suprême il doit tout savoir
et tout appréhendé il sait qu'il a vécu
des choses avec spider man et s'il n'y a
pas de déclic quand il entendra son nom
il ira de lui même s'intéresser à ce
héros dont il a oublié
l'identité
merci à d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je
voulais absolument revenir sur spider
man noir comme avec une grosse vidéo car
je n'avais pas eu l'occasion de le faire
de façon vraiment réfléchi étant donné
que les dernières vidéos sur spider man
date de décembre donc voilà je suis
content d'avoir fait et puis bah
j'espère que mes idées vous auront plus
n'oubliez pas que ce ne sont que des
théories ce n'est pas dit que tout ça
arrive si la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez
pas évidemment à laisser un pouce bleus
et puis un commentaire sur comment vous
imaginez le futur de spider man
maintenant ou pourquoi pas le sur le
possible retour d'andrew ou de toby dans
le futur de marvel et puis n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner c'est très important
merci à vous merci à nantes vpn que le
lionheart soit avec vous écoutez c'était
argot rock allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]